we got genuinely bad jobs news from
February as we often do in the first
part of each month we get the jobs
numbers from the previous month 180,000
new jobs were expected for February of
2019 at the actual number just twenty
thousand new jobs
180 expected twenty actual this is 89%
shy of the expected number still jobs
were created so in a sense that's good
it's better to create jobs than to lose
jobs but remember that the population
expands the number of people who enter
the potential labor force goes up each
month so you need some new jobs just to
keep up with population growth and that
number depending on which estimates you
look at is ninety to a hundred and
forty-five thousand new jobs just to
keep up with new people that are of
working age so twenty thousand new jobs
is actually quite bad now just like I
did under Obama
I don't play these partisan games where
I either sugarcoat or exclude
information that's positive or negative
on the basis of the party of the person
in the White House I'm not doing that
the same way that under Obama I made an
effort not to over or understate the
importance of any one number I'm also
going to be totally upfront with you
that this is not a clear trend under the
trump administration yet there's some
wage growth not much more than inflation
but there is some wage growth that's
good the unemployment rate is still low
that's good although we're starting to
sort of learn about what the the sort of
other side of low unemployment it can be
in terms of a very difficult labor
market for hiring people but when you
combine a job creation number that's
eighty nine percent lower than expected
with a newly downgraded estimate for GDP
growth for this year which we just
received that's not looking great I
think anyone who is honestly assessing
the numbers would admit now that being
said not everything that happens now is
because of trump good or bad there's no
sort of like one point at which we can
say okay
from now on everything that happens in
the economy everything that happens with
jobs everything that happens with the
stock market it's now only attributable
to Trump or it's still attributable to
the previous president this is very
complicated stuff over a full term of a
president you can probably start to say
that most of what we're seeing is more
than likely the result of the policies
of the administration rather than the
previous president that's the reality
but it's better to just not play
political games with this stuff that's
unfortunately how our media and
political system works and there's a
really important thing that I continue
to bring up all of these numbers are
constructions the unemployment number
job growth all that stuff I don't mean
that they are made up that the
statistics are made up but what I mean
is job creation as we measure it GDP
growth as a measure of how the country
is doing it's all a construction we've
decided that these arbitrary measures
tell us how the economy is doing we
accept that they tell us how the economy
is doing it's circular and it has no
sort of independent existence this is
not like a moral relativism or nothing
has any meaning thing it's just that we
decide what tells us how to evaluate the
economy and then we accept that those
are good measures for doing so there is
a really strong case to be made as I've
been making for years that a lot of
these numbers don't really tell us much
about the overall well-being of people
in the country they don't tell us
anything about the damage that we're
doing the country to the planet in terms
of climate change and pollution and the
environment they tell us nothing about
how the mere idea of infinite growth
forever is a destructive and literally
impossible idea because at a certain
point you stretch the planet to the end
of its resources within the context
where we accept that this is sort of how
we evaluate how the economy is doing
these jobs numbers aren't good but more
broadly what I go back to
every month when we get a new report
about expected GDP numbers or job growth
versus expected job growth is that we
have to figure out what the relationship
is going to be of humans to work into
the economy around them because it's
changing very quickly it's not
politically popular to talk about but if
we keep ignoring it
we are going to end up at some point
it's not exactly when in what I guess is
to put it in an understatement sort of
fashion a rude awakening about the world
around us the numbers are bad but we
also have much bigger issues that aren't
being dealt with here